today we're going to examine overhauls
brand-new form which for the record
looks completely normal and we're
especially looking at how powerful it is
and just why it even exists just why at
this point in a series you should know
that overhauls base quark allows him to
disassemble and reassemble anything he
touches this is how he's literally been
able to explode people with a single
touch and then bring them back to life
well not everyone but you get the idea
his control over things is so advanced
that as we saw he reshaped an area that
looked like this into one that looked
like this and he's such a great guy that
he threw in some deadly spikes on top of
all of that so it's no surprise that
given his level of power he had another
trick up his sleeve with this new form
having many many advantages now this
form is the result of him disassembling
both himself and one of his fellow gang
members and then instantly reassembling
them back into a combined entity the
most obvious advantage that we can see
is that he now has four arms each of
which is capable of using his quark and
for those of you wondering the reason
why he couldn't just create new arms for
himself without fusing with someone is
because overhauls quark doesn't allow
him to create matter he can only
rearrange infuse things that already
exist and in addition to his two new
arms all the injuries that he had are
immediately healed because by making
this fusion he's essentially created a
new person so all the damage he took
from both Mario and deku has just
disappeared which is basically cheating
but what we'll have that discussion
another time and the third advantage of
this form is that he can now use the
quirk of the person that he's fused with
so because he fused with Nemoto he could
now use his confession quark which
compels anyone who replies to him to
tell the truth and like I said overall
can now use this confession quark albeit
in a really weird way it's kind of
confusing to think about because in some
way I guess no moto is still alive in
there somewhere
I'd be really interested to see if that
mouth on overalls hand would be capable
of disobeying him or whether he can make
it say whatever he wants either way the
only real drawback of this monster form
is that overhaul still feels the pain of
being blown apart so when he was
destroying both himself and Nemoto it
was by no means a painless process
I reckon they would have much preferred
the fusion dance if given the option now
overall admitted that this is some
he's never attempted before and it's
pretty clear the only reason he did it
was because he was getting whooped by a
bunch of high school kids so essentially
it's a last-ditch-resort to kind of give
him more firepower as he can activate
his quirk from multiple angles which
makes him super hard to fight against as
nite ize sadly found out but moving on
i'm gonna quickly focus on the general
look of this form as we can see the eye
socket from the motos mask is quite
prominent on overhauls right hand so
it's clear that he didn't just fuse with
the person but also the clothes that
that person was wearing and I think this
is further displayed by the black fabric
from the motos cape which just seems to
be like everywhere also worth pointing
out that the bird mask that overhaul
always wears has now seemingly fused
with his actual face yeah everything
about this is is pretty gross with that
explained I'm gonna touch on something
that hasn't yet been seen in the anime
so if you don't want to know any manga
spoilers then thank you for watching and
please subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next week but for the rest of
you who already know or don't really
care I want to briefly touch on the
evolution of this form that we'll be
seeing in the next episode so overhaul
fuses again with another one of his
Expendables this time it's katsu Carmy
but the thing that he creates this time
around it's really just a different
ballgame just look at it spine I mean
I'd be lying if I said it didn't look a
little bit like a dinosaur
it has about 12 arms by my count each of
which are capable of using overhauls
quark and these arms aren't just created
from fusing with Kasukabe he's actually
fusing with the rocks and stones that
are surrounding him which all kind of
add to whatever the hell this is and as
you can see chisaki is just chilling in
the mouth of this giant structure kind
of reminds me of this guy now the main
benefits of this form are pretty similar
to the first one
like he regains his health and he can
use his quirk with a ridiculous amount
of arms I guess the main difference is
the size of this one is so much bigger
and he's combining himself with like the
surrounding environment and look at
Katsucon Mays head at the top there like
is he still conscious or nah but yeah
guys that's pretty much everything there
is to know about overhauls two monster
forms I have a few videos planned for
January including a long vigilantes one
that I'm currently writing and don't
forget that we're having a Q&A with the
voice actor for me Ryota gotta sometime
in January so be sure to keep an eye out
for that
and if you haven't seen it already be
sure to check out my video where I talk
about the five most likely courses of
action now that miryo is Quercus thanks
again for watching and peace out